here's 144 I don't know if you want
about her 44 yes you'll just pass that
ends up but we want those and up if you
want mama to pass out that was a fail hi
I'm Hannah and over the world okay it's
mom and this week we're gonna try
something a little different we've never
done any content related to pranks on
this series but lately my boys have been
asking me about it non-stop so I'm gonna
try something I'm gonna give them one
week to rank me as many times as they
want no I don't know what they're gonna
do or when they're gonna do it but we'll
see what happens wish them luck
so the rules the boys can prank me for
one week and within that week they can
try as many times as they want
knowing Wyatt I don't think he's really
gonna be into it he's not much of a
prankster and he's kind of serious so I
imagine Jax that's gonna be the one
doing most of these pranks but one
thing's for sure they have to use Matt's
help for this most importantly because
the boys don't have any money besides
that they can pretty much do whatever
they want except no bugs no bugs laying
down the law I just need to add that I'm
the coolest mom ever for allowing my
kids to do this
all right so what should we do oh we
could be ten we could milk chocolate
milk and meat end up he likes up poop in
his underwear relaxing on the ground no
what about a candy bar oh yes you want
to do a candy bar reading about that way
you'd like that don't you look that
music that's a yes let's do it
[Applause]
Yuriko
okay so it might be hot be careful no
just got this smoosh it on the one time
I forget to bring my clothes into the
bathroom to take a shower and this is
just this is classic Matt because he is
he's not paying attention to those kind
of logistics like is she dressed
does she have makeup on does her hair
look like it just got sucked up in a
lawnmower chocolate
so it was just a classic first prank of
like the one time I don't have my
clothes just got out of the shower of
course that's what he felt me at my best
thank you so they did it they got me
with the poop
they succeeded it was really gross
alright Jackson you gotta come up with
some other pranks Rosie pooped on the
sofa
[Music]
that is a great idea inspired by the
doggie poop Rosie
and here's what they do - looks like the
talkie doo-doo
I think the bed is the best place right
there just right there and maybe I'll
tuck them a blanket over it
yeah I know that because I know my dog's
poop as the person who cleans up most of
the dog poop
I am very intimately knowledgeable about
the consistency color and texture not
proud of that smell and it's real it's
totally real yeah you're such a liar
Rosie's poops are chunkier well you fed
her all that pizza try choosing poop for
those first two pranks it's very
indicative of the mind of Jackson he's
very poop oriented these days almost
turning seven years old so you know it's
all I thinks about cut up your game
Jackson that prank wise word Jackson I
are in the bathroom you can't get away
from Anna we have to hide in a bathroom
the Jackson had a great idea tell me
what it is it's cockroaches on the craft
let me stop the noise oh my gosh
so how are you gonna do this I can't use
the real ones right yeah I can't wait a
minute high five nice okay so this
morning we're looking for the perfect
roaches did you find some Jackson here's
a humongous one that we could control
and here's 144 144 yes you'll just pass
that ends up but we want those and
double if you want mama to cast alpha
Jackson I have something to show you
Jackson and Wyatt see what's in there
grab it big bugs yes she's gonna be
freaking out yeah what do you think
these are door yeah
how are we gonna trick mommy with this
we're gonna go inside here and then I'll
fill a pantry then I'll scream
yeah I can close that door and hide them
this is gonna be good this is perfect
what do you think buddy
oh yeah thumbs up so I guess they
weren't done with the pranks they needed
one final hurrah to just get me really
really good I walk out of the bathroom
and I hear Jackson yelling for me what
what happened so many cockroaches in my
laundry room and I was just like are you
hitting me my first thought was burn the
house down and then my second instinct
was just to run away
I think I blacked out a little bit like
my heart stopped a little that is truly
truly my worst nightmare proud of my
reaction but you know when it comes to
bugs it's every man for themselves I'm
not saving anyone when it comes to bugs
do too so what did I learn this week
absolutely nothing except for the fact
that my kids and my own husband will do
me so dirty if they have the chance like
that was low and you know what else I
said no bugs and they did bugs so you
know what this isn't over I'm gonna do
something about this just you wait
so I am going to get the boys and I know
exactly how to get them where it hurts
I'm gonna mess with the PlayStation and
I'm going to hide it in my closet hey
Jackson the PlayStation 2 player
did you lose it revenge is best served
cold dude where is it
what do we do who are you smiling
because your teeth look very deep Jonas
but I'm worried okay we have to find it
stop looking at me with those teeth okay
I'm serious I you know Kate Jackson wear
it search everywhere we're gonna be okay
daddy left this door open do you think
someone could have gotten in I don't
know why it is that didn't quite work
because I can't keep a straight face I'm
really bad at doing pranks and I know
that this is exactly why I just can't
keep a straight face when I'm trying to
trick somebody so we've pivoted we're
going to try to prank Matt and I think I
know how I can get this to work I will
leave the PlayStation overturned in the
entryway so he thinks that one of the
kids threw it or something like that or
they were messing with it and while he
does that I'm gonna go outside so that
he can't hear me laughing he can't hear
me giggling
okay no more pranks promise almost truce
truce peace Thanks okay thank you
[Music]
so that's all I got for it today I'm
Hanna and if you have any good prank
ideas leave them in the comments cuz we
might just do a few more on each other
or you can always text me this is a real
number I don't respond to all of them
because I get a lot but I do read every
single one now if you'll please excuse
me I just stopped all of these cookies
with toothpaste and I'm going to go feed
them to my family till next time oh boy
[Music]
we're the pranksters